hello hi and welcome to this video
playing super song sorry from canada
don't think I'll ever play them right to
know pro let's have a quick look at the
profile Mia nothing special okay so a
six this is a funny line it's not that
bad not as bad as it looks going for an
exchange variation here and see if the
a6 move is useful for him now normally
black go see six so that Bishop g5 can
be answered by we should be seven now it
feels a little bit like a six isn't that
useful but Wow well the night absolutely
does not belong on that square or we
will see what is what is up to some
night before here I know let's develop
yeah what to do we should h4 I guess
taking doesn't make much sense that
frizzy 7 ok so what is he up to we
should f5 or what ok I'm going here I'm
sending it back with a 3 anyway so on 95
95 yeah it's got 97 then so that doesn't
does it help much maybe just this yeah I
wonder if Quincy to as a move it looks a
bit strange but maybe try maybe you can
just play rook e8 being inviting there
no he didn't feel like going for that ok
so should a 2 I just correct the Queen
position here
yeah let's put it here Bishop f5 is a
move that you can can play they don't
want to trade the bishops maybe you
could have played rupee 8 i'm not sure
that i actually threaten something there
okay um once you go 494 to c5 let's play
a prep move for that okay well hmm just
Queenie to maybe it's a bit wrong to put
it on the e-file but other squares look
strange I'm threatening Bishop a
six-year probably to take on d5 okay
okay that's something tactical going on
that I'm not spotting with the rook on
the e-file against my queen hmm
otherwise g5 is really a weakening a lot
has to be some some clear point okay
let's go here yeah that is a point you
are building up that building up that
pin I still wonder if it's really a big
issue that pin mm-hmm how to play
the environment I mean I don't really
fear that he takes so much there but I
don't see a good square for the Queen
this is my main problem here I don't see
where to where to put it and unpin maybe
still here I mean if it takes this is
not a problem I don't think so and we
should just six I go to the one
attending we should be one I don't mind
to trade the light squared Bishop save
if that happens as f5 is so much
weakened
that's a tricky position i thinkI pretty
bad has pretty much has to go Bishop g6
no he doesn't feel he has to okay okay
night okay this is a playable move it's
not terrible but still I'm surprised and
now yeah I want to move the night
probably here like night f1 g3 is
something that might happen
and f1 g3 Bishop be one this is the plan
yep neither five is a good move I'm not
its own what I'm going to wanted to say
is covering or looking at at five that's
a good move I should have played 93
anyway this is not it's not an issue
okay I'm happy to take this so let's get
something going here maybe just be five
all right playing quickly now queen
before and now I have to go here i guess
or what is the best way to do it hmm I
Scott b6 coming and I want to go to the
three if possible hmm maybe this one
all right nicely covering this look to
you one now is some kind of self pin
which is which undesirable maybe I can
do this time morning I really has
stepped up and time wise yeah I playing
great moves now okay 10 go them
and I just had to be able to quick i am
not satisfied with those moves to be
perfectly honest but i had our time that
he was playing great moves and instantly
check 9f towards a huge issue no I
wanted to play g3 ok maybe it doesn't
make a big difference I'm in bad shape
anyway check check check yeah I cannot
really tell what happened to me a
completely killed me when the time got
to God lo he was playing sighing to play
very quickly and very good moves yeah
continues to do so yeah ok what resides
yeah well there was a weird game around
here um I should be in excellent shape
but I simply didn't didn't go a kid
didn't get anywhere I like this and what
was the big deal yeah okay night XD five
is good I didn't get to move I was just
thinking that this should be
strategically good as well this is g5
stuff and so on but yeah well he kind of
repairs this position now
and actually three is a little bit
better but that's done that shouldn't be
bad now from here I start to play
instant moves and very good ones really
very good ones like taking here which
isn't a completely simple decision i
think but you just took it and have no
good move now well be six going back
it's also good preventing 95
I have this one like BAM yeah this is
strong creating one rookies excellent
here for black so that 16 is not coming
with 166 is not coming yeah I could have
played hoops see one why can I do that I
thought Bishop d3 would be a problem but
okay I can take I can take here and this
is okay and then look see one comes into
consideration i didn't i didn't forget
this so much that's all very good it's
all very strong check h5 strong and
after each one loss yeah it's difficult
to play this yeah the engine says f3 is
the best but with this is already highly
critical you have to go somewhere here
oh yeah I'm just lost I really wondered
what went wrong here I mean okay maybe
this is kind of normal
campbell's like g5 always make me feel
uncomfortable like how can this be
played and black is not going to get
into trouble it's a completely
unnecessary weakening but anyway so
Quincy to ya and the engine wants to
play this immediately but it also likes
this but this is what the computer is
giving us a move I did not consider at
all and at some point yeah I mean the
idea is to probably take and take 125 so
yeah the line that the engine is giving
full black is absolutely absolutely
terrible something like this this is
this is awful black oh I don't know that
I didn't think about it something like
this at all and tier 95 was possible ya
hear this position was kind of equal but
he really played that very well when the
time go down he made absolutely no
mistakes my original idea of course was
this but he's called b6 so this is why I
pushed a push that immediate be five
which was not necessary i can play
whatever him just a normal move well be
five is necessarily bad but the coming
complications he really played much
better than I did okay well thanks for
watching